if you were to use energy as quickly as
a hummingbird you'd have to eat a fridge
full of food or about 300 hamburgers
every day in order to survive they use
energy so quickly as they fly so so fast
and a lot of the flowers they feed on
are really delicate and if they were to
perch on them then they would pull the
flower off they have to hover in one
place which is really energy consuming
it's one of the most energetically
expensive activities in the animal world
I think so they use energy really really
quickly in order to survive everything
they're really tiny the smallest
hummingbird is like the weight of a dime
and the largest is 20 grams which is
maybe nine dimes stuck together they
don't have much room to store fat if you
were really heavy with fat then you
wouldn't be able to fly so they have to
feed on nectar many many many times
during the day if hummingbirds didn't
have flowers to feed on they would
starve in as little as two hours so next
time you need a snack be thankful it's
not a life-or-death situation
all bees buzzed but bumblebees are one
of the very few types of bees that
actually take that buzzing sound and use
it like a secret weapon to get pollen